yeah all right and we are live
flashpoint returns what a special guest
debunked we got to build in man Rick at
Wilhelm scream from YouTube Twitter I'll
let you take your introduction man tell
us about yourself I'm will hum scream
community content creator for destiny
love the game I've been playing it since
the destiny alpha which hard to believe
it's been four years since that it was a
fight it's a fun time and yeah just
trying to keep consistent keep the
community as informed as possible and
really appreciate being here you know
pleasure to have you man pleasure
talking I said thank you thank you so
much I mean I would definitely been a
kind of cross crossing paths for a bid
and shout out to hooking us up with
destiny tower that's a great we would I
don't know it's a great phrase Facebook
group and um like I said I got a chance
to check out your content and it's
really passionate and um it's always
good to see you know fellow lovers of
Destiny kind of get together talk about
this game that we're so being passionate
about you know I've you know I mean I I
think I've known avi bonta's for almost
three years although we've never
actually talked it's kind of crazy
you know you know people it's sort of
funny you know people in a game and then
you know people through the community of
a game it's yes yeah likewise I mean you
know I literally met you boxes at my
first like Guardian con you know yeah
how we linked up and um yeah man it's
just been cool ever since just talking
destiny and we just can't stop good we
gonna get this thing going so a man but
we got some news going on in this is
tois week yeah we got it's actually a
perfect week so with a guest on
sometimes world will typically cover the
12 the news for the week but these are
kind of more open discussion topics we
got gambit kind of some things talk
about their crucible changes and just
overall will definitely dive into
what do you want me to call you during
this by the way we didn't cover that
just Wilhelm scream best creamer or
people say both squeeze I wanna butcher
it scream seems to be a little easier
sometimes when you're just trying to
think of it really fast you know but
yeah I'll just kind of get some general
thoughts about for sake and it changes
and anything we've all heard coming up
so yeah so let's just dive into this we
can bungee and get into a couple of
these topics we've got coming so games
comes around the corner guys anything
you hope to see in their little footage
reveals anything else that they might be
dropping or you kind of done and you've
seen all you want to what do you guys
think that scream go they don't jump in
after I'm gonna be honest I mean as
someone who tries to keep as up-to-date
with the community as possible I feel as
though I've seen enough to the point
where I kind of like I always sort of
like to leave those is sort of like a
reveal a little bit of a surprised you
sound like you bought learn I mean
there's there's so much information I
think out there if you're looking for it
you know I mean Bungie tells you a bit
and then the community will even tell
you more if you're if you know who to
look for
yes so you know when it comes to the
reveals I think I know what to expect
but I always look forward to being that
little bit of pleasantly surprised with
new stuff maybe with the lore I think
there might be I don't know I don't know
if they're going to reveal that at
Gamescom but I'm sort of interested in
like I don't know I feel like there
could be some secret things that we we
might figure one thing and they're not
actually mmm trusting oh yeah you bet I
mean I'm kind of the same boat I mean to
be realistic
I've we've seen a lot you know we've
seen a lot they've been very you know
forthcoming with a lot of information
you know I'm hoping it's probably a
little bit kind of like what they did to
III where I got a chance to play gambit
and I think they may reveal something
bit of information that we didn't know
but um you
that's pretty much what I expect and
which I'm hoping for I don't need like
any full-blown you know breaking news
expose he's you know forsaken so I'm
satisfied man I'm hi I think the tribes
are serving their purpose but a
community right now and really getting
us ready mentally and how to prepare
which i think is kind of like the first
I've seen from them in a while like
really telling hey this is what you need
to do you know this is what's gonna
happen to this and you know so obviously
we'll get into it what about you so I'm
ready man I'm like yeah so I don't know
can I know they'll be playing gambit
again I wonder if anybody gets any new
maps or a different build or anything
like that maybe the opens just give him
the same thing they've been taking
everywhere I'm sure they will just
because it's like they have nothing
pretty prepackaged at this point so
probably gonna give the general stuff
but I'm sure they'll drop one new
trailer like everything else so just
don't tell me who the final raid bosses
that's all I am well for Wilhelm's sake
it was like when we talked about it
before my point is that me personally
and I know we've gone back and forth and
like it's marketing the game definitely
needed some help it's like I'm not
arguing that but for me personally when
I'm playing the game I wish I didn't
know the kid was gonna you know be
getting his comeuppance oh yeah where I
don't I think I'm good with you I'm like
I've got a lot already it's like you
know just spoon-feed me a little bit
here and there little little pieces and
I'm good so hopefully we don't get too
much so I'll just have to go a little a
little more silent over the next last
point is gonna be a real flash but next
week so guys we're not looking at any
content anymore we'll see what comes out
of next week so we've got a lot of
changes a lot of changes coming with
both forsaken a patch on the
twenty-eighth crucible gambits coming
with forsaken weapon slot changes so
whole bunch of stuff is moving around
and heads up for you guys again when it
comes to the 28th definitely make sure
you have all your inventory and weapon
slots and all that stuff or weapon
changes and damage types ready before
the 28th
when that stuff happens it's all walking
in but we've got some stuff to talk
about with gambit you want to take this
one you I'm gonna kind of cover the
intro and let you guys go at it oh yeah
jump off do you settle fee and then
we'll go ahead we'll talk okay
so they said four seconds are in the
corner a game but will soon be unleashed
but they want to discuss their goals for
gambit they said they want to put PV and
PDE and PvP together which is a really
cool thing
Wilhelm you and I were talking about
this a little bit it's it's a thing that
only destiny and few other games can do
and I'm think we're all pretty excited
to see them put these two together
finally because or always slow if you're
they're only doing crucible or only
doing PvE and finally giving kind of a
mode with both where people can excel at
one thing or another it's like you may
have like one person on your team who is
the only one who goes through the portal
because they're a beast at PvP sniping
but you got three people on the other
end who are good at the other side and
you can actually work well and it's
gonna be some different team builds it's
not just like the Hovey's and the
snipers and the beast people at pvp
mm-hm
it's carabao it's gonna be both so
that'll be really cool they want to make
it accessible to all skill levels but
give it depth which is always good we
always want more depth pretty much at
this point they casualized it too much
so give us some more and that's what I
was saying there's always a role to play
and that's what they're talking about
slaying enemies scooping up moats
invading all that stuff will be good
they said communications and isn't
required but I'm sorry but if you're
gonna be successful pretty sure it's
gonna be I'm gonna go drop a blocker now
okay I'm gonna go run across and try and
stop them from you know getting getting
it in and all that stuff so it's it
looks like it's gonna be a really fun
mode I wish I could get my hands on it I
know you got two still so jealous of
that
it's fun it's really they really nailed
it and like I said you can just play the
role that you're comfortable with if you
if you're a PvE guy you focus on the
blockers incorrect grabbing up those
moats if you're a PvP guy you just got a
lot of a little bit of mischief in you
you go through that portal if you cause
havoc or the other side their opponent
so it's really cool it's a nice marriage
of modes and something that like you
said early like fun a few things that
only destiny and kind of pull off you
know something like that so yeah you're
gonna love it it's good it's very
addicting
yes that's gonna be the issue so we'll
hum you had for this one have you got a
chance to play it yet or just gonna
succeed like I I haven't I've mostly
seen it and I do have to say like you
know as a sort of a PvP guy you know
weapons roles were always kind of a
thing that I loved that was kind of as a
PvP guy weapons roles and grinding for
different roles on a weapon was what
like always encouraged me to play PvE
and in doing that like that sort of
grind and farm actually became really
really fun so it was always kind of like
even though I preferred PvP PvE had sort
of a unique place for me especially when
it came to like night falls and doing
like the solo trying to solo them you
know there was a real challenge there
and like I don't know destiny even on
the onset of d1 was such a unique
sandbox and that nobody had really done
anything where there was even this that
there was even sort of an equal give and
take of PvE and PvP within the game of
like an FPS on a console like nobody had
done that really so when I thought about
it in my mind you know I always tried to
think like what would be the perfect
marriage of these two things like how
exactly would you do it and you know I
probably came up with maybe five ideas
of my own mm-hmm that I thought were
pretty good
none were quite as good as what they've
done as far as what I've seen and as
someone who you know I have you know
some friends or used to you know when I
played on the different consoles I had
other friends who really only liked to
play PvE they didn't like the PvP just
frustrated them like they would play for
two seconds and then just say I'm done
with this yeah yeah and not always
having that thing to do like you do the
nightfall you do the raid you can go do
some strikes and stuff but when you know
they're doing the strike specific thing
no those are more encouraged now I
suppose that the game just moving into
forsaken is going to be a much more
fluid PvE environment
there's just gonna be so much more to do
anyway right but with something like
this
I don't know I feel like you we're it's
gonna attract so many new people to the
game I agree I agree big time Big Time
it's a great point this is a great point
I completely agree and like I said as a
PvP guy myself you know I also used to
think about moles we used to think about
this like what could they do to kind of
incorporate it not and even think of
anything like this so I'm insane scream
on which heaven it seemed buddies yeah
I'm very jealous that you got to play it
oh yeah I've been that way for a while
yeah but you guys are in for some fun
make no mistake like anything you hear
about it though I've not heard anything
like okay Lloyd 99% positive about that
thing which is the same way and it's
like from that much uniform like
excitement about one new mode awesome so
it one of those things we know Dustin
you should have going for it but yeah
we're gonna have a ranking system in
gambit itself completely upon its own
called infamy so they say at the high
level infamy is a progression based
ranking system or completing matches or
ANSI points winning matches a little
greatly accelerated Khan losing that
just still earns you points just fury
for you and kind of works like glory no
I'm sorry Gloria valor never cross those
in talking forgive me experienced reward
players with unique game at weapons on
armor which i think is crucial if you
can't i also by the way these are some
of the coolest emblem like level
progressions I've seen yet like I love
the color scheme on these game bat
pieces right here these fiver I want
this one it's pretty nice big if I could
add one more thing about gambit that I
just kind of find interesting too is
that I think this is probably amongst
maybe well definitely with them within
destiny but probably within any Bungie
game the most user generated game type
they've ever done meaning this is really
I feel like everything coming in
forsaken is very much community focused
and generated right I don't think they
could have done anything
L
I think they realized that that we
really need to just do what the
community is telling us and that's why I
think you're getting so much positive
feedback because everyone's like well
how they did it they actually just did
it for us you know it's great to see a
company do that - yeah absolutely
especially when I think they needed to
hit rock bottom right certain you know
the community actually want it because
we all know we all felt at least on most
of us at the end of the d1 lifecycle
that they finally got systems in place
right and you know I'm not gonna go too
long in this because I'm gonna make a
long point but as mean artists have
always talked about you know Wendy - it
definitely seemed to be a philosophy
shift right it definitely seemed 2001
she definitely seemed to start catering
more to a casual crowd and not that
hardcore grind that we'd like and you
know thanks things like the summit and
other things that transpired since
they've been slowly turning this thing
around and just like you said scream
it's been direct result of listening to
the community and getting that back in
and getting those thought processes back
in the end the guys you know the bigger
guys in the community you know flying
out there now them have a special role
and I think all that contributed to it I
think we kind of see in this little
Renaissance right now and it is good to
see well I think you guys took all the
words so yeah as you said it's like
January 1st like some switch got turned
some authority was given to say do
whatever the hell you want to do to try
and fix this game and they've been given
free rein to be more transparent with
the community bring people in make the
changes they need to throw everything
possible they can into Forsaken not
space it there's so much in forsaken I
can't figure out what's actually gonna
be I mean the fact that we have
potentially story connecting to endgame
and actual in the game zone which we've
never experienced before I know the
upside down that's all say about that
but there's so much on top of like ever
we would always talk about vlogs time
like story and crucible and okay what's
the Dreaming city occasionally I have to
remind myself
gambits a thing like it's a it's your
third bubble and I'm just like holy crap
so no I'm I'm insane
for this and it's just one of those that
now they've got a progression system all
on its own you're working together just
even one more thing to dry it in case
you ever played World of Warcraft there
was a lot of crap to grind for
reputations in there too and yeah we
know we have our share now yeah
absolutely
yeah so they said to start designing
infantry infamy ranks they wanted to be
kind of granular and they did a similar
thing for crucible talk about it later
they're splitting the ranks more into
smaller tiers
so each rank is gonna have like I don't
know if it's like you know Guardian
guardian one Guardian two Guardian three
brave one two and three I don't know how
they're gonna call it but they're
definitely gonna break him into three
tiers each and then finally your top
tier legend is still gonna be one big
chunk so if you're up there in the top
you are just in the top which is gonna
take some work after this one I also
want the infamy links the function more
like Valor each rank will require more
infamy points than the last win streaks
will reward win streak caps at five but
doesn't get reset as much nice that's I
like that yeah so if you go straight for
ten I mean keep going here keep the
momentum going man I really like that
and your win streak will not be reset if
you join a match in progress like oh
that's great
in addition they said you can earn
infamy by completing game but bounties
so bounties are coming back all over the
place we've seen there's gonna be more
everywhere he's gonna have his share to
each day The Drifter will have a special
selection of bounties you can get you
know once you reach level 50 there's
also a special weekly bounty you know
we've been asking about this one coming
This Means War yes that's my baby the
true meaning of war so as long as we get
things like that that are equivalent
love it I love it man there's definitely
time investment and engagement and
keeping you in the mode so I like I like
to hear that kind of stuff yeah so
that'll be a powerful piece of another
thing they instead of and you're right
it's gonna depend a little bit but a
little bit can you guys see somewhat
back now
okay weekly and then so the bounty will
award a large enough in points and a
piece of powerful gear so just in taking
that stuff out of your milestone tray as
they said mm-hmm and then my stream just
grows yeah you sound you still like in
and out a little bit if you want me to
start reading or whatever let me know
but yeah you can talk about the back
screen for a little while if you guys
can see that one it also yeah yeah you
guys go ahead and do battle track fix
mine yeah I'm definitely on so basically
yeah like I never say I was like you
know obviously we can found you that
kind of stuff you know they're gonna do
things to kind of increase the infamy
infamy rank which I like and then as you
scroll down you see that um you know the
Guardians they look like some cool armor
set uh scream do you see stuff like it
some kind of like a new rocket launcher
on this warlock there's like a Lola bird
emblem they're getting they're getting
very neat yeah yeah I like that I like
they like everything kind of specific
yeah yeah to the actual region and that
kind of stuff so um don't you can be
versatile I say love it love it there
you go now you talk you want to feel
special when you get this game so
chicken burger can you my trying to
reach Christine or something like that
yeah go for it go for it I'll like let
me know if you back it will take sting
off me
but um right okay sorry guy yeah no
worries man no worries man ended up
behaving I get it there we go
I'm sorry like this nah no worries man
yours
I'm summaries no instruction you guys
you still you still cutting in and out
ok I'm good you're gonna have to get a
job you had it bad bro alright ok yeah
just come right back
just come back alright so hopefully you
guys can see me anyway so pretty much
until we get back
understand so pretty much we gonna
scroll down into uh shacks and he's got
the looks like a criminal crucible stuff
going on screams checking this stuff out
he's got the yeah is that at the bottom
of the page I'm looking for you scroll
down you see Shaq's going on right there
it's it's like starts off with the title
magnificent if that part of the Bungie
update sorry I'm this is for the this
week at Bungie correct yes that is
correct this is for the the is it this
freaking wedgie for August 9th or is
there a new one
there is the year the lowest one for the
August 16th August 1600 the oh there we
go
I'm sorry I'm just please talk more
about it alright so pretty much
basically said during a combat reveal
stream they used crucible as a proving
ground a show-off how the new weapon
systems work and you know activities of
guardians in year two so then they
brought one of the senior crucible
designers in then he's basically talking
skies Kevin gains any basically said
he's you know he's glad to talk to us
about how things gonna pretty much
change going forward for the new season
so one of the things he mentioned was
that uh his goal was to make earning a
high rank and glory not feel like your
second job glory ranks will be gained in
loss a great break points gaming laws
have been retooled
to reduce the overall climb to higher
ranks
the weekly award has been fixed and it's
gangs have been dumped
then they said his next goal is to
recognize the achievements of players
who did not receive the weekly awards in
season three so the change is elevating
in regards to this will be players who
completed season three will earn bonus
rent points for completing their first
match in season four and it does not
requires a completion of any previous
weekly milestones the third goal he had
for crucible was to encourage more
players to strive for higher glory ranks
this is interesting cuz a lot of people
who not playing grow as much so is there
he's saying our losses in the
competitive playlist no longer reset
your valor win streak yeah just you
gonna stop in a minute
raid off it has been re-enabled during
competitive gameplay control and clash
will be added to the competitive
playlist here's another one lost streaks
have been removed and finally for this
goal we're currently investigating act
it's activity reconnections to
competitive crucible for players who
encounter an error mid game this will
not be available at the launcher
forsaken but we're looking to add this
feature post-launch so based on these
goals we heard right now scream like
what do you think about this stuff that
they talk about well adding adding radar
back to it definitely that changes up
the that changes up a crucible playlists
vary dramatically more than most people
I think would give it credit for it in
fact if I was to think of like what is
one of the more like fundamental changes
you could make right you know to to a
any any sort of PvP game type in any
game not just destiny it would be either
radar or no radar it's like somebody who
kind of came up in the in the like the
halo 3 halo 2 competitive days and if
anybody remembers that not to talk about
it absolutely oh yeah this is Bungie we
got it alright if you remember the like
they had the MLG playlist they had the
hardcore playlist before that and that
was no radar there's
you know there was and there was a
reason for that was that if you were a
good it became more about gun skill and
a less about well actually no it became
a little bit more about gun skill as
well as just map knowledge rather than
rather than knowing maybe you know sort
of timing your you know when to attack
or rather sticking with your group right
because I I feel like when you when you
sort of when you go back to more of a
radar based interaction system in any
PvP game type mm-hmm you really what
you're really doing is you're really
throwing it back on the game to do the
things that you want more than the
individual gotcha so so like when you're
you know for example in this now that
you'll have radar you're most likely
going to stick with your group a little
bit more and then you know kind of
combine forces with everything that's
you can bring to bear not just your
weapons but your supers your grenades
all of those things where is like when
you're no radar that one lone wolf can
kind of go off on his own and using his
own personal skill you take out you know
more people perhaps because they're just
not prepared for him they're not ready
for that is correct now that I'll go
ahead sorry should point screen and then
I think so that so that changes um you
know it changes it in that way that
being said I don't know if that's
necessarily a bad thing because the the
that game type I feel or that specific
playlist I feel like was kind of going
with suffering a little bit I feel like
it wasn't as accessible as I liked it
right but that doesn't mean that it's
it's where it needs to be no I found
that even if I wanted to play I had
trouble getting into games because there
really wasn't enough peep it would take
a while it would take a while maximally
longer it would take longer definitely
definitely and it's someone who always
likes to pair like multiple stacking of
different things that I'm doing that day
you know I always like to be able to do
like my crews bounties and stuff I would
love to be able to play that playlist
for those things
but it just you know take too long and
so you pretty much answered the question
was an a she was that what about when no
radar was initially introduced for
competitive modes like competitive and
trials like what was your an issue
thought ah I'm very curious as to now
you know they removed when you first
heard look we're gonna be gonna remove
it by what was your mindset then well
for a light level enabled PvP type which
was what trials initially was I always
kind of thought in d1 trials should be
no radar okay but mostly because one it
was a it was meant to be a competitive
playlist but also because light level
was enabled you kind of you had an
advantage if you had a higher light
level but that could that advantage
could be diminished by a skilled player
who knows how to work a flank and work
with different people so in that sense I
actually thought when light level is
enabled
maybe not for iron banner but uh for for
trials I thought it was actually kind of
a good thing I I enjoyed it even though
most people they didn't but I but I
actually liked that because it really
did feel competitive and I didn't feel
like I was just kind of getting trounced
by people who had the best gear all the
time which is you know it's part of it I
know it's late level enabled they want
you to grind for gear but um it should
also be one of those things where you
should want the gear in the game type so
you should you know you should want to
be had that feeling of like I want to
play this more regardless if I'm winning
or losing right is almost that gears to
carry right I got right to make you keep
wanting to go I'm and go forward right
and I felt like sometimes the
frustration of trials with radar yeah
kind of
it was I don't know if it really
affected me so much as it would always
affect somebody on the team you know
there would always be somebody who after
that first loss was just like I'm done
no no right so I like that you know
you know I don't know if they I don't
know what they're gonna do with trials
that's a big you know that's a that's a
softball way up in the air I don't know
who's gonna catch it but um it's for is
for this game type yeah I think honestly
I if it encourages people to play it
more and that's that's what I think is
the most important yeah I'll just jump
in real quick on it yeah these were huge
to me when I saw these bullet points I
was like you know as a fellow crucible
guy I was like wow this is some changes
you know I'm saying because they're
actually stepping back on the radar you
know the law sting law streaks on the
the law streaks I think will be
controversial to some of the hardcore
community only for the standpoint that
you know and we'll get to infamous
rhetorics later but um you know only for
the people who love that challenge and
and they want to feel special for
acquiring this rare item right because
as we know right now the way it stands
you know rhetorics only like a smaller
percentage of the community even has the
gun right right all streaks really kind
of detergent went on a streak you lose
you know you lose more you know our
glory as you lose more so I mean it
definitely can be discouraging and it
can definitely be you know something
people don't want to invest a lot of
time in if they're having issues so when
I saw that I'm like okay is this casual
izing the mole you know I mean and the
other thing is you know as far as the um
the radar I'll be honest when I was
first heard about it I was like okay I
like it right make it more hardcore you
know oh you gotta use your words it's
gonna break up the whole team shot
mechanic that seem to be playing destiny
to everybody kind of groups up like you
said one person can go off on that flank
and then kind of you know maybe do their
own thing but rather the panel of
competitive I've kind of changed my tune
on it it's just you know it's not it's
not that it's not fun I just see that
people get so frustrated yeah they just
like I'm done I'm done with this guy
though this mold so those interesting
that they're going there and as far as
that last bullet point as far as the um
you know they're looking into the whole
reconnection to a competitive crucible
match you know whoever person who drops
or aramid game I think that's huge
and I also would like them bat to extend
to you know let's say you're playing you
draw a competitive match you guys drop
the first two i've been on teams with
people just just leave so now it's just
as two one four one on four massacre and
I felt the puck the player like myself
who actually has integrity and stayed in
the game should have something in place
to be rewarded for that you know right
so that's where I'm at with that what
about you and then we move on to these
next goals yeah and I would also say
that like you know you you need people
to want to play the playlist and if with
the with the law streaks I mean you just
even as like someone who played pvp you
know active avidly it I would never
really go into that playlist unless I
had at least one or two other people
playing with me yeah absolutely and
because you know we you're gonna lose
your if you're on your own you're gonna
you're never gonna get to five you might
I've you know I've won four in a row yes
several times and but there's always
that one and it's just because
eventually you're gonna get somebody
who's just Bullet fodder and you can't
you can't really do anything about that
and then you know the whole your whole
it's discouraging and you know you want
to feel as though you can just jump in
on your own I've always said that this
is one of those things where it's it's
the greatest game to play with friends
and it's the most like accessible game
one of the more accessible games to play
by yourself so it's like you know you
want it's it's better with friends but
there's a lot to do when you're when
you're just by yourself so like I always
want to feel as though I can just make
the progression on my own and then when
I have a friend we just go that much
fast
you know great great great points
so um hold on l-boogie ask what do you
mean by radar so basically LPL bogeys
it's basically upper right hand corner
in crucible there's usually this
quadrant of red indicators that let you
know how close in what direction an
enemy is from you so that's pretty much
when we talk about in reference to that
so yes I'm gonna move on to these other
go so on we've got that and then now the
other goal they talked about is removing
the time pressures associated with glory
ranks right so he says pinnacle crucible
rewards are now or water via quest some
of the quests will ask you to engage
with valor or glory glory ranks then it
said these quests will not go away at
the end of the season so this is gonna
be an ongoing thing now let's get to the
juicy car screen here we go Reggie
exclaim or is being retired in season
four
oh no players who have already earned
the weapon will still be able to equip
it and use it
claire's will be unable to earn Reggie's
claim or be on season three now we
continue to the more drama in the
community right now Jax will offer a new
quest that players can compete to earn
rhetorics broadsword a companion weapon
to redress claymore rhetorics broad
sword features a similar talent
arrangement but it does not share the
law and triumphs associated with the
Claymore once you've earned the weapon
random role versions of rhetorics
broadsword will start dropping from
crucible engrams each drop will have the
trademark outlaw and desperado / that's
the one I claim or has now so the new
one also will have each job will have
randomized barrels magazines and master
work perks players who earned Reggie
Claymore in season 3 will receive
additional bonuses the these owners will
be granted an exclusive emblem when
redeeming the corresponding triumph
claim our owners will also be eligible
for drops of red Rick's broadsword from
crucible and greens even without
completing the corresponding quest and
finally a new crucible reward will be
added via quest in season four so this
is a lot to digest in reference to
Reggie's now screen if you haven't been
paying attention I was there with you
is going nuts
I can imagine right so we all know the
history of rhetoric learn more how
difficulties bungees put out the numbers
in reference to the percentage of people
who actually have it it may be like you
know 1 to 5 percent if we did our math
I'm not sure but it's very present
actually have this gun
I've been trying it's difficult so um I
want to present this to you now based on
this all this information what I've been
hearing is that a lot of people feel
this is unfair
they feel that they if they had the you
know obviously they had to claim or now
they feel like bungees giving it away
you know what's your mindset what's your
take on all this register claim or
versus regex broadsword stuff well with
a lot of these things you know when they
say that something is being removed and
replaced with something else because you
know a was over it was too much or too
difficult and now B is going to be a
little bit I always kind of have to I
always sort of take a watch and wait
approach as like how it really depends
is is rejects claim or still going to be
that much better than the corresponding
weapon and the broadsword and if if
they're I mean if they're generally the
same with maybe like the claim or having
a couple extra perks you're gonna upset
5% of the population right which you
know they're they're hardcore PvP guys
they'll they'll continue to play believe
me if it's extremely if those like two
little things that you get or whatever
the little extra that you get from
having it previous to to forsaken really
improve the game that much you're gonna
you're gonna upset a lot of people a lot
of people so I I'm curious uh you know I
would say that overall yeah I think I
think these things are generally
generally good is it is it exactly what
I would have done when when you know
you've just implemented a web
in the last expansion and now you're
sort of replacing it would have been my
way of doing it I don't really know
exactly I always kind of a Mike of the
idea that these that even though we have
exotic and this is kind of going to a
bigger sandbox go for even though we
have exotic exotic quest lines I always
thought there should be like you know
for example Shaq sells this weapon that
there should be some sort of like like
sub ark quest line they maybe is
different you doesn't have to be the
same as a exotic quest line but that
that allows you a to maybe get this
weapon but that's exactly it's funny you
said that that's exactly what they
intend to do oh it is yes okay yeah I
missed that part
no it's cool it's cool but basically
what they're doing is this so this is
simplified all the rhetoric there's this
viewing what it is like okay so if you
have read your claim right mm-hmm
you you obviously keep it to season four
but this new version which is this
rhetorics Broadfoot which is basic all
it is is redder exclaim or with random
roles right that's what that's what
broad so it is so what the community is
upset is they're saying hey you know now
these guys get a chance to get the gun
what Bungie is saying is hey you guys
had already earned it right just by
playing crucible you'll be able to get
it out of a random crucible drop where
as the community that doesn't have it
have to go through the whole Club my
life I resented that thing twice kicked
the modem in the face you returned it
the best part of what to talk to you
about was like hey I'm not gonna have
this discussion so we're up to the the
infamous Frederick's Claymore versus
broadsword and just break me with me
screen which is breaking it down so just
to simplify it you know what we
basically was going on was the fact that
you know red rooks broadsword is
basically claymore with the random roles
that's just what it's basically gonna be
the better version of claymore now for
the people who had
Claymore when they come into season four
they're gonna get some type of emblem
and they're gonna get instead of getting
a broadsword off the edge of the jump
when they play crucible burn engrams
wrap their chances to get it will be
increased and have that accessibility of
the top whereas someone who's never
gotten Claymore and in playing you know
crucible you know they have to complete
the the quest to go get it you know I'm
saying they have to go to and apparently
it's very difficult they're saying it's
going to be an extremely difficult quest
to get it and that's how they can do it
so the argument now at the community is
like hey you know this is not special
for the guys that have it they don't we
don't feel special anymore so what do
you feel based on all this Claymore
stuff II wear you out with it
uh I mean as I'm not one who really sees
myself even getting it in the next few
weeks it's nice to have the option
something for me later like for the ones
who grinded that lay their butts off for
it and like everybody who gets her to
exclaim or you had a hundred in like
ninety thousand people who had whisper
which is not an easy thing to do I was
dragging my brother literally through
that like one other guy finished the
mission as he landed in the final boss
fight so yeah we basically to me in the
whole thing and it's like and that's a
fun cool challenge but not an easy one
to do yeah 8,000 people in comparison
had rhetorics I mean that's been a oh I
mean it would have been cool if they
would have given it some other perks
that sort and also I just don't want
another duplicate grimy like another
things just outlaw and desperado coming
back the same way or I think it kind of
takes away from the ones who actually
spend the time to get it now if it was
another thing if they had a bonus of
doing something they get like some
recognition and you know there was
something they got for doing it that'd
be really cool but you're basically kind
of shooting them a little bit well they
are they are getting they are getting a
reward for having claymores
basically they're gonna get like some
emblem and some lore and stuff triumphs
associated with it the minute they
actually attempt crucible is a log you
know go to shacks if they've had a
reggie's claim warrant they're gonna get
this stuff so we assume an emblem some
other special law stuff some triumph
thing some some
type a special reward for these guys
maybe not be the most grandiose but they
are getting something I'm saying but we
have to remember to like you were saying
he is that um that you weren't excited
as much as just that outlaw desperado
combo the broadsword is gonna have like
randomized barrels random roles you know
magazines and master work perks so a
broadsword is going to be different you
know and you can with random roles you
might be able to get some you know some
crazy combinations there so even with
that information you feel like it's
still not enough for the hardcore guys
that out what grinded for it II no no
I'm thinking I'm here I didn't like
here's 20,000 things think real fast I'm
trying to I missed all the fun part the
card again yeah is happening man I know
the network today has not been kind to
can see oh yeah it's like half and half
Lucy Lucy but um was going to say uh
scream yes
final verdict man final final verdict on
this thing man final verdict is I think
there's always going to be a certain
number of people that are upset by
things I think in this case they're
limiting that number which might you
know I it might be just the you know the
the lesser of two evils
either you you upset like as you say
maybe 5% of the population or you upset
or you or you continue or you leave it
how it is which I you know I don't know
if that's necessarily that might be the
best option in my opinion of just kind
of leaving it and maybe with the new the
fact that there's no loss right or just
the new win streak in that playlist you
knew what you might you know you
probably will you'll see that number
climb where it won't be like 5% of the
population I bet if you
just left it how it is and they and they
changed how the playlist functions I bet
you would see that number climb up to
about 25% which I feel like maybe where
that should be
um but you know I mean if it's just if
we're really just kind of renaming
things here and and and they do and they
do get something out of it I think it's
really gonna be kind of based on what
that I know they've kind of stipulated
what they what they will get but that
doesn't know he's seeing it doesn't
always really tell you so satisfying
it's gonna be oh that's a good point
that's a good point
so you know I I'm sure that there'll be
some people have said either way is this
something that I think is gonna be the
the like the make or break of that gun
or that playlist or crucible or forsaken
I think it'll probably be fairly low on
the totem pole yeah I could you know as
if they felt it needed to be changed I I
can understand that yeah I feel like
maybe I am lacking a little bit of
developer insight which my gang were
much we've very needed for this specific
case but I'm not gonna be upset by it
I'll jump in and then we'll move on with
Barry regex for the FIR for this sir
listen I mean selfishly as a person who
did not get rhetorics you know in that
trust me I'm still trying I mean I
actually like the idea of this like
prestige weapon that only a small
percentage of the population will have
because it was a bragging rights it was
a tournament you know like a crowd in
the tower
you know like look at this what I have
sure and I think that's would make
destiny destiny I remember first playing
trials I mean seeing people in the town
with trials gear and trials in wow I
remember they had the Egyptian god be
like what is that you know it just made
me want to grind harder for it so I felt
that was the right direction now we know
you know the next season is coming out I
did I was very curious like how are they
gonna handle it so I had a strong
feeling obviously it was gonna go away
as some capacity they would introduce a
new gun which I believe it saloon Luna's
how pistol everyone saying is supposed
to be crazy so I was very curious about
the fate of rhetoric so me myself was
personally grinding now to have it you
know just so it was unique going
I am happy that broadsword exists
because I did feel that ultimately when
random roles and all these other weapons
register was going to be outclassed at
some point right you're gonna find a
weapon even though that no weapon exists
with the outlaw desperado combination
you figure guns with roles are gonna
just outright outperform the gun so I
was happy to see that it was coming back
I'm like okay cool so it's just like you
said screams like what half are the
larger half like yeah I never got a
chance to get that gun you know now it
random roles you know I can go back in
there's gonna be no more law streaks
let's go and then you got the other half
they're like yo wait a bit you're just
cheapened by entire grind like I get
that motion I get that sentiment you
know so I think you nailed it on the
head it all comes down to how these
rewards are you know received right
people run if it's really majestic if
it's really something that stands out if
it satisfies the community so that they
that blow is lessened I'm all for it but
if it's like hey here's a shader here's
an emblem get out of here and I would
say I totally agree with you in that
I've always felt as well that destiny is
kind of a game that I think benefits
from the idea of certain people have
just gotten certain things certain
people have gotten either lucky or they
grind it for it and there's a certain
percentage of the population that has it
because honestly it motivates a
community like no other thing that I've
seen perfectly so I I you know I
completely agree with with that
prospectus on it so yeah I write I think
it's gonna it's gonna really come down
to that to see how upset that 5% of the
population yes I think it would have
been fun if they maybe had done
something where I think they are doing
something like that but maybe like if
you if you have it defeating you know
this many enemies with it in PvE opens
it up to you know something else or in
or if you need to do a certain amount of
things to allow it to become accessible
in which is what which is what they're
hinting because saying yeah
long quest line it's hard so I'm
expecting you know it's not gonna be
easy I think they date the vibe I'm
getting is they're going to respect the
time of the original owners by letting
the new owners know hey if you want this
you're gonna have to do an insane grind
on request
right I mean you're gonna have to use
you know grenade launcher kita lb
whatever you said like dig the vibe I'm
getting on me again I could be wrong but
based on the tone of the text in the
table it definitely seems like this is
gonna be like the true meaning of war on
steroids like you're gonna have to do
some things you're not saying to get
these things I really like that
alliteration by the way the last go
continue to promote Rumble as a third
mode so the changes earning a place in
the top three in Rumble will now count
as wimp and the correct number of Valor
points will be granted so if you
committed to any of the rank ladders
that were established in season 3 thanks
for making the fight lively we support
the competitive community no matter your
skill or mood feedback coming so they
trying to just keep on improving the
crucible so are you a rumble guy in that
this I have a lot to say about I might
have more to say about this than even
any other people because I am a huge
Rumble guy okay I used to play in those
Halo like first to a hundred Rumble
tournaments you know it's like a
three-hour game I've loved any kind of
rumble playlist in any sort of game for
forever and I've always it was one of
those things that when it wasn't here I
was upset I was I was really sad for a
very long time when it came back I'm so
glad that it's a constant now because I
there was a few when he would come as
the weekly playlist it was like honestly
all I played that humble guy like that
buddies I loved Rumble and this I as far
as rewards go I think is the best
possible way you can do it because those
top three guys are usually pretty close
I mean I you know I've lost one
sometimes by one kill and it's you know
20 it's like me and the two other guys
who are in the top three are like at 26
everybody else is at 14 and I'm just
like I should be getting something for
this you know like yeah I should do
something for concise should be getting
something for consistently doing well
yes because I will play this playlist
more than anything else if I feel like I
can write and but that was sort of the
thing that was preventing me was that
this was the playlist that I loved to
play the most and but it was probably
the one that I was going to have
achieved the least progression in as far
as any PvP um you know just because the
odds are against you mmm the odds are
always against you in that standing on
your own fighting like that's not a band
it's not easy so making it kind of like
a 50/50 thing I think I think it's good
oh good with the top three you go with
that I am I am I think that's a really
fun change and you know if they had
wanted to maybe nuance it a little bit
more like I'm trying to remember what
game did it but it was like well
actually I don't know if it was a Halo
game but I don't think it was
specifically for okay the game I think
there was a there was an online
tournament a while back that I remember
what they did was if you got first you
got so many points if you got second you
got a little bit a few less and it went
down to I don't think you ever got zero
points right it was just kind of like
you got that scale from right that scale
and if you I think it was it they did
there was something like if you got if
you progress so many you know if you
finish in such-and-such a place for so
many times there was like a bonus you
could get or a bonus you can unlock um
you know I don't know if it necessarily
needs to be that nuanced for one
specific playlist but overall I think
it's a good change very smooth I'm which
a minute I mean I definitely I've got a
chance to really getting a lot of Rumble
indie to like I used to play in d1 but I
was very happy it came back you know I
like to change from eight to six as much
I thought eight might be cool and where
they brought this day it was a little
too much chaos trouble
is definitely about that so yeah this is
cool man and then like just you know
overall with these changes I just think
it's one of those things that it's like
I definitely can see some of the
hardcore competitive community overall
not just on Rumble talk about like like
the glory stuff the streaks being
stopped you know I could see some of the
hardcore competitive guys you know might
raise their eyebrows oh now you're
making it easy yeah you know because I
get that but at the same time I think
I'm going what your thought process is
scream which is I think buns you may be
looking at it and say look there's so
many of the community that it's not even
experiencing it and they're not playing
the mold right so exactly you know
they're going in they go on you know to
get one win and the next thing is a four
streak and your valid goes down from
whatever down the breeze let you know
whatever those heroic yeah you know I
think they're looking at like look we
gotta make it a little bit more
accessible you know and I don't have a
necessarily but I don't feel that the
changes are that extreme we just got to
see how the regex thing plays out I'm
very curious about that but no I'm okay
what about you overall with all these
changes so far let's course Chris but
you overall I could yeah I mean I could
probably could probably talk I could
probably talk you know at length about
you know all the the the little things
that maybe are this or that or the other
but I mean I'm doing it out of sheer
love it's like you know if I'm if I'm a
teacher this is a student who wrote not
just an a-plus paper but you know you
think he's going places you really you
really want to scrutinize them as much
as you can and I think this has always
been my case with destiny is I've always
really like scrutinizing it because it
was just so unique to me and I enjoyed
it so much it's like that parent who
just wants to see their kid do well yeah
so essential so much potential and you
have so much enjoyment witty so you just
want this thing to be better right and
if I say one more thing about the rumble
thing typically it's just that uh you
know the top three that's really good
there's not gonna be anything any real
you know I don't know if on an online
database I mean I don't know how they'll
run it they usually do their own
algorithms I don't know if you know the
the top three finishes as far as
counting as a win mm-hmm I think will
only really go so far as to satisfy
those people who want to play a playlist
and feel as though they can progress yes
and not to any sort of bragging rights
standpoint because the guys who play it
for the competitive they're never going
to be satisfied with a second-place even
if they get a good reward they'll just
say okay well at least I can I don't
have to you know at least I'm getting
something else before my for my trouble
for me you know like I'm always going to
the win anyway it'll just encourage me
to play it more and moreover it'll
courage a lot more people to play it and
I think ultimately they'll do I think
that's the design goal I think out of
all of these changes so we shall see so
we gonna get into the next part which is
getting social so you talk about you
know the launch of destiny to David
taking feedback from ghaida game's
matchmaking systems from the social team
so they brought in Design Lead Steve
Dolan to detail the changes that will
happen to make you easier to keep your
fire team together so on it also has
meals for clan features so basically
he's talking about the upcoming changes
to social systems and he's gonna start
with the strikes I believe so fire teams
that are formed in some activities will
now stay together once the activity is
complete yeah this applies to the
following strikes gambit and crucible
he said note this does not apply to
competitive or the scores are wildly
disproportional players will be put back
into matchmaking to find a new team and
activity reconnection starting with
forsaken if you disconnect from a guided
game you'll be offered the opportunity
to reconnect to the activity if it's
still active we reserve their spot you
know for up to three minutes that's
great that's good
that's good shake after that guides
we'll be able to backfill the got a game
with seekers that are currently in the
queue then when it comes to guided raids
these recommend daily connections excuse
me will help with individual player
disconnects in the case that an entire
fireteam disconnects we want to minimize
the impact to raid teams going forward
players be able to take their raid
checkpoints out out of guided games and
use them in the normal version of the
raid if you all disconnect form up your
fireteam again and head into the normal
version to continue on your path to
total raid destruction so this is a lot
to digest just this section right here
yes yes I'm gonna start with at the top
I think this is fantastic I think with
the fire team's aspect I can count one a
number of times that I've done you know
either match main heroic strikes a match
made you know crucible you know and one
you would like to especially was a good
group but you see these guys you know
you don't even have to communicate and
these guys got a good strategy down and
laying the rifts down and I got the Luna
faction boots and like these guys and
then the match ends and you had a good
feeling and then you go back to orbit
and it's a whole new group again so I do
miss Tech's I believe correct me if I'm
wrong screen in d1 which strikes I
thought we did stay together right if
you had randomized matchmaking on like a
strike would they keep the same group
together on the onto the next one
in heroic strikes is that you're a
master even regular strikes this regular
strikes am I wrong for thinking there
god it's been a minute long I know it's
been a mean I I feel as though there was
there was something like that right but
always maybe I don't remember if it was
like that at the start it might have
been implemented later gotcha gotcha so
we're gonna have that four strikes gonna
have that four game we're gonna have
that four crucible so I'm assuming not
glory but like I said um valor you know
hey if we playing valor and it is a good
group going guys you know win
you know you get the opportunity to just
stay with that team if you just don't
press anything and exit you know I mean
right yeah so overall with strikes game
and crucible is that a go for you was it
no for you a yet well yeah with this I
think it's good I hope it has the effect
that they want again I think it might
come down to sort of the implementation
of it it's like I you know I simply
staying in the game is is great you know
I hope people will know enough to do
that as well as like what I mean by that
is sometimes I think people need a
visual cue yes so like I I would have
liked if there or maybe they I mean
maybe they have done this or maybe this
is how it'll be but if there was some
sort of like opt-in opt-out like button
so like at the end of the game it says
you know good would you like to stay
with these people click on this because
I've seen other games who'd that have
done something like that and it really
like a ready up kind of yes yes cue
almost in a UI right yeah right yeah so
I you know I I think it's a good thing
overall it's certainly something that I
you know I I felt the the the dissuade
meant if that's the word like a really
of a really good group just disappear
and go ah man you know and I'm trying to
track them down
so I you know I just I think a lot of it
comes down to how I see that if or how
it displays itself if it's a you know
always a good thing overall and I just
hope it it you know from the from the on
said it works out the way that they that
that they hope or has as much effect as
they hope absolutely now in reference to
the reconnection in Subsection when they
were talking about disconnecting from
guiding games you know or on guided
raids where they almost given that three
minutes to get somebody back in the
queue yeah all that stuff is fantastic
alright so you can with that oh yeah
that stuff is Fanta
I mean the fact that they've been able
something I think is maybe you know I
don't wanna I don't wanna I don't really
want to like dis on them at all at this
good because I really think they've done
you know when you see somebody making
such a big effort yeah I just want to
say okay you know things forgive it may
be a little bit overdue yes yeah
especially gotta games because that's
all about it that's all we've given them
little credit for some quality of life
stuff they are they're they're they're
up and they're they're up in their game
a bit haha clan update so since launch
fifty percent of you have hit max
ranking your clans going into forsaken
there are two major things that we
wanted to improve a clans give you more
reason to play with your clan mates and
make clan perks more interesting so this
is how clan XP is changing when you
start your journey in forsaken Hawthorne
will have three daily bounties they can
be completed alone or with a fireteam to
grant a small amount of clinics Pete
once your character reaches level the
new level 50 Hawthorne will add three
additional weekly bounties that grant
large amounts of cranek speed but
require you to fire team up with your
clan mates so on here's example of some
of those perks that will be impactful
for the clan stuff which is a rank three
increased resilience when you're in a
fireteam a clan mates huh interesting
rank five great a chance to receive
additional etheric and barren resources
on the guest is all yeah this is all
real stuff when collecting them in the
reef whatever Derick light comes back
and I hear they're rank 6 the weekly
clan now stone also grant a master work
core oh so yeah I mean that is that is
interesting that's really that's really
interesting yeah honestly Wow something
I didn't really think they would do or
at least it's gonna I mean I think it's
gonna play big into how many
into clans which have only have I feel
like sort of been left in the periphery
a little bit um I would like to see more
more clan inactive stuff with the I
think bounties on Hawthorn just alone is
a great idea and yeah that's sort of hmm
I mean I really like the whole perk with
the group thing bad that's that I really
enjoy and yeah we'll I think clans will
just build from that which i think is a
good thing yeah so overall I mean it's
something that I wasn't even aware that
they were gonna be doing I can't say
anything I I don't think I could have
any negative there's any negative
comment I could have about that I don't
see it going having any sort of downside
whatsoever other than just improving you
know player 2 player participation
absolutely man I think these are great I
think um a lot of it is you see the
mindset seem to be for them to really
encourage clan clans and clan grouping
and joining acclaim to show the benefit
of it I think resilience is like ABS
that's big you know you get increased
resilience the way you know that the
system works right now between you know
recovering resilience you know we all
know just like that that's a big deal
you know it promotes team playing
getting more resources and I'm a big
mass to work core guy that you know
that's a big thing too and how important
those are gonna be exactly especially
with forsaken especially with the new
commitment to leveling up the weapons
it's gonna require a lot of cores now to
go through that process of leveling up
these legendaries you know each stage
grants a little bit more as we don't
know if you got a chance to see that
combat reveal scream I think yes i oh
yes the long one yeah where they way
through the hole that I mean that was a
little bit yeah it was you know one
thing that caught my eye was that you
know the old way of upgrading you know
turning something into a masterwork he's
definitely changing
and each time you put a call in or like
the first level or whatever is gonna ask
for glooming when you get to the higher
levels I believe seven is the max ET
bonds this would correct me but uh you
know I think what it is is now once you
get to a certain part let's just assume
it's like five to seven I couldn't wrong
those are gonna ask for course some core
is now gonna be more essential than ever
so any type of source to go to get cores
I think it's a huge deal now you know
especially with these these roles and
everything going on right now so this is
good stuff I smell some core farming
method videos in the core loot cave I
love all that stuff right now strike
good Titans running around oh yeah yeah
I like I like the idea of I was always
you know in vanilla destiny I'm really
talking about vanilla destiny when you
had the weapons that you need unlock the
perks and then you had to infuse the
power brackets and I kind of like that I
always just wished I was like you know
this would be great the only thing I
wish they did was I wish that this
wasn't just a power thing I wish it was
a power thing but it was because of what
you were unlocking on mmm you know I
mean like you you infuse some stuff that
unlocked those additive person really
they're really upped you know it could
have been just a name at that point you
know like I it might have just been an
aesthetic thing where it was like
III don't know if I know it's right
right and I just always just kind of
like I just wish it said something else
other than just power like I always just
said something like you know the Slayer
of worlds
[Laughter]
something crazy along those lines and it
would just be it would have just made it
more fun but I like that there was
always like that material thing that you
needed to get as well as unlocking it so
it's ready to unlock them and then you
need to find the materials I felt like
that and I think that's I oughta stay
feel like they've sort of given me my
aesthetic need as well as going back to
that a bit I'm on that Rhapsody I think
that the casual community probably does
not miss any of that running around
Earth the Cosmodrome
spin meadow and what was all those old
botanical fusion cores oh those were a
grab but I understand what you say
standpoint that for the hardcore MMO
sensibility and for us guys that had
that addiction we part of us does miss
that like we do daily process that was
ingrained in us and it's like yeah I got
this gun I have it unlock the full
potential yet use it right now I gotta
go get this stuff and yeah I definitely
it's certain aspect that missus I can't
and I and I kind of see it also from
like the more casual perspective to
especially at this point in d2 is like
we're kind of putting the toothpaste
back in the tube a little bit yeah and
that's not necessarily an easy sell to
people because you're essentially saying
I mean like going back to two vanilla d1
you know it's like one of those things
where if a buddy of yours in the first
month had like two or three exotics you
were like oh man yeah what do you been
doing no life you know now everybody had
several in the first day or two or you
know the hard work right so I kind of
like going back to that like you know
what are you doing you know yeah
absolutely
for a second oh and um this resilience
in its is it PvP resilience I don't know
man that's a good question I mean they
haven't specified if that clan
resilience is gonna be across both modes
or one I mean I would
so it's both they didn't they didn't
specify it usually remember the old
terminology screen would be like you
know increase this against enemy
something rice yeah yeah yes so we're
not seeing that terminology so I'm gonna
say it may be across the board and all
activities if it's across the board that
is that is super interesting yeah that
it's super interesting clay that means
there if it is across the board there
really that that means that clans are a
major priority yes got to say that there
and they've never been but like mmhmm
yeah pushing that stuff yeah absolutely
so looks like it's in some express
yourself and they've got this cool
little remote going down so they're
giving us a sneak peek of one of these
uh emotes coming on September 4th looks
like a little tight in there hitting the
swing it was like I scrolled down to
that as you were saying it that was just
a perfectly time pulling my energy bar
to hold it down for my guy like it's
just like you said if you don't have a
clan someone's always recruiting they
want you to get out there so now we're
gonna go into going out with a bang and
this is about the crucible labs so uh
next week a new mode will be featured in
crucible labs we're expecting explosive
results and co-designer Andrew Weldon
he's here to set stage so pretty much
Andrew gets out and he talks about this
past weekend they've had it I haven't
touched on crucible laughs at all so I
don't know if you have I did the first I
did the first time it was here I missed
the second time because I was actually
on vacation but I enjoyed it I thought I
mean I think it's a cool thing um yeah I
think it's a really cool thing now I'm
actually I'm maybe you can answer this
question for me is it based off of
user-generated games for my
understanding it is not it is arms
these are modes that they intend or may
be implementing at some point during a
life cycle of destiny too
but they want feedback you know they
really want feeling for they just throw
it in a while so for my understanding
you know they had some other mode a
militia bothers him because he played I
have not touch crucible at once but I do
remember when the announcement half
and what they said the mindset going in
was for it and I definitely do remember
them saying hey we're gonna you know try
these moans we get your feedback you
felt this you felt that you're gonna do
this we're gonna change that that was
kind of like the vibe so you know now
basically you know they said people have
had touch this updated version showdown
and based on they said the information
they're gonna make some changes on nap
and they said they receive feedback on
both these two modes that they
introduced which is lockdown and
showdown
they said that both the feedback was
that both modes felt too tilted towards
the competitive playlist isle of
gameplay which is the 4x4 you know for
before around based higher-stakes etc
and they say you guys are right that was
the target experience for both modes
this next time around they're going to
swing the pendulum the all the way so I
guess this is more of a casual play
playlist if they're gonna do it's gonna
be called scorch so they're saying this
is very deep complex the serious rules
and here's the sarcasm you spawn what
sports torch cannon everyone else spawns
with his corpse cannon oh my god what
scorch cannons nuff said that's it I
guess they've heard the feedback and
they would've tried another boat you
don't say like I said just run around
scorch cannons and blow people up so uh
what do you think about this I don't
know why but an analogy of a joke a
friend of mine said he would play on his
child when he would have one this was
years ago I hope this doesn't run off
the rails too much is that he said he
would love to play the joke of one day
my son's just gonna come downstairs so
I'm gonna have three glasses on the
table I'm gonna go to or these are apple
juice ones not that's good I don't know
why but for some reason that triggered
that in me and that like it's gotta be a
freakish he'll probably be a glorious
one its glory o glorious Vegas yeah so
they're right with crucible labs as a
whole I think I mean I I think that a a
tester game type game mode is is great I
hope
one of the things that I kind of hoped
that they did with it was that you know
that you could still maybe earn some
reputation from it in some way that it
wasn't sort of just so standalone
because I think if honestly if
somebody's willing to kind of if they
won't if they're invested enough to want
to go and you know test different
archetypes of playlists' that's a cool
person you know that's somebody who's
really loves the especially the PvP side
of this game so kind of give them that I
I didn't know if and and this is I'm
just sort of ignorant to this fact is I
wasn't sure if this was and this was the
question I had before if all of those
playlists were based off of private
match generated games or if it was the
basically just Bungie saying these are
some things that we like that we think
could work and that we want to maybe do
and we before we just put them out there
based on you know previous negative
feedback we want you guys to kind of
give us our literally burst right the
vibe from what I've hate round I'm
hearing with this thing what right which
is your second point right so I think I
think that's good unto itself
I think if you if there was some kind of
like like I don't sort of refer to the
Forge in in Halo where you could create
a forge map that eventually would every
you know month or so they would review
it and your map could end up in the MLG
playlist mmm and like because some the
the people who were creating those maps
were doing so because of you know what
the MLG or the competitive community was
just telling them so they were really
trying to help you know fine-tune those
things and Bungie just simply didn't
have the time to do it but they could
implement it so if they did something
like that moving for I don't know if
they will I don't know if I don't think
it real really detract from the playlist
as a whole because like I said there's
gonna be so much stuff to do the fact
that you have a crucible labs and the
fact that they're introducing these kind
of fun raw romps which that really
sounds like it's gonna be a really well
yeah I think is just great as a whole if
they did do
thing where you're testing and sort of I
don't know if you I don't know how you
would necessarily send it to them or get
them notified that there's you know this
is a really fun playlist maybe you want
to check it out
I think I don't think that could do
anything negative for the community I
think that I would actually maybe create
a whole new type of individual who
enjoys this game maybe people who just
want to create game types yeah yeah I've
always been a fan of people I've always
been a fan of just thinking about man
what would be a really fun change to
this game type or what would be I
remember back in d1 when private matches
came out there were so many things that
I wanted to try for the respawn game
type like I really wanted to try like a
6v6 respawn like not a 66 revive
playlist I don't know if they ever did
that but you know again sort of just
free it's a free associating at this
point but I think overall very very fun
thing yeah but III I commend them for
this kind of thing and like I said you
know getting the feedback for the
community of things you want to
introduce I think it's cool you know and
um you know like I said this looks like
a rocket just like you said like a crazy
I actually might jump in for the first
time last based on this oh yeah yeah so
it looks like they got some dates is
like the 21st or Tuesday 10:00 a.m.
Pacific time they're gonna do a pre a
free-for-all version of it so as long as
you write the Friday the 24th they will
do a 66 mode of it at 10:00 a.m. Pacific
time so again they said it's wild and
zany that they've had a lot of fun
playing at Bungie we hope that you have
a blast with it as the final labs
offerings before year two begins and
then we get into kind of some
maintenance stuff so update 2.0 is
around the corner and they're talking
about the report you know issues of
people blocking having solstice armor
issues deployed so they working on that
they got some PC odd behavior in the
character screen they working on that
and um they're talking about resplendent
master work so I'll fly through this
pretty much that they've they've
confirmed their social worker no longer
upgraded after the conclusion of sources
of heroes this week we can confirm that
players will be able to complete
objectives to master work their
legendary solstice armor to resplendent
after sources of heroes ends on the 28th
of August so this will require players
that have already upgraded to the
legendary sorcerer summer resplendent
and because the statute of Heroes that's
in the towel will no longer be available
to upgrade the scorched and kindled sets
so as a reminder these armor sets only
generate element two orbs during
solstice of heroes so and then lastly
players should be aware that valor ranks
reset at the conclusion of season three
if players do not unlock their master
work for achieving legend in their valor
ranking by the end of season three their
valor rank what we say and they will
have to begin anew in seasons 4 so
little things yeah yeah for social stuff
no quality of life stuff I thought was
cool you know
yeah people wouldn't get a chance to
finish this you know kind of get it
updated when you can still kind of
continue on that's cool and um then our
bling for that this is a good one
forsaken preparation this is very good
and the fact that they've done this
they've done an incredible job with this
I have to say sorry in a row don't
completely agree completely agree man
so yeah they basically set the table so
arm as destiny to cross into the second
year players may observe a number of
issues in the week before August 28th in
September 4th
while we working to document known
issues for this week long transition
players should be prepared for some
general turbulence all right to set
expectation here's a sampling of issues
confirmed so they'd let you know ahead
of time get ready for this exotic
weapons will lose their power +5 power
mod in preparation for the year 2 mod
system but legendary weapons will not
until September 4 so exotics by Bob Fox
nightfall strikes will not have scoring
until September 4th some tooltips and
item descriptions may reflect year to
item behavior even if item functionality
is not updated into September 4th so
that's interesting some UI stuff some
also again the next one some tooltips
and I'll inscription
when you really were still reflect your
one behavior also September 4th
even though item functionality has
already been updated for you to gear 2
weapon slots the juicy one will be live
for all players which may cause some
weapons in players inventories to go to
their postmaster so as a result of this
all players should ensure their
postmasters are clear by August 28th to
prevent loss of items that's a huge one
so and then some gear 1 power weapons
which previously had an element to
attribute will become kinetic for year 2
it's interesting element through
attributes for a handful of targeted
year 1 weapons will be changed and
locked to a specific attribute for year
2 now we've got confirmation that I
believe it's one of the eye closed
weapons the shotgun that's really not
gonna last night are both going to be
you call and [ __ ] with your cable
company and then things happen that's
that's really cool which is great in the
prep stage as far as they're basically
getting us ready so arm or other year
one energy and power weapons and players
inventories will have the elemental
attribute slots for year two so they can
still we can still expect more details
so either back for a little bit like how
you feeling about this prep stuff and
all these things that may be happening
that we have to kind of prep for you
know when for second half is during that
one week prior to launch I mean I think
it's really nice honestly we get the
weapon slots we get to kind of play
around get a feel we get the vault space
before you can clean up your shaders I
don't know fish shaders actually clean
up then I think that there's nothing
shader cleanup on that day honestly
forget yeah I don't even mention
anything about shade exam what my
[ __ ]
yeah no it's on the 20th I'm looking
nice nice so yeah I mean honestly all
the stuff is good getting everything
prepped so literally you don't have to
worry about much and just go in and play
and this is I think we probably both
said it before you can go into forsaken
and just enjoy the content I don't
login spend 20 like an hour messing with
my vault doing all that stuff I just
want to login and go so I I'm totally
fine with this the stuff moving around
the changes I mean it's just nice that
they're giving them heads up about it I
just I hope the list is pretty accurate
because I'm definitely working on
getting my Manan set because that's like
my ones go but remember you got to lock
that manning into that uh element you
want oh I have two of them it is gonna
scream rich like I have to so I'm going
to lock those into the one that's not
gonna hopefully pull from the
collections then I have an option from
l3 but I'm honestly hoping most of the
random roles make your one kind of
useless
so that's my hope really laughing which
is which may eventually happen Oh scream
man what are you thinking about this all
this prep stuff I think it's well I
would agree with him is that like I hate
when I feel like I'm like waiting to
make sure that I know exactly what I'm
doing before I do anything because I
don't want to have to do it again or I
don't want to miss something you know or
the best method to doing something so
like yeah all this sort of open prep
work that I mean honestly that the thing
that really stood out to me is that it
was the post the the post yeah because I
have so much stuff in the end up keeping
a lot in there because I'm always sort
of curious as to what will happen like
at a changeover you know I've done that
in the past and I've had some sort of
interesting interesting results I'm not
gonna do it this time thank you for
telling me Bungie so yeah I would agree
I think that it's it's all just a good
thing and I like to be able to just like
jump right in play as far as things that
I'm gonna be yeah I'm very curious is
didn't they say and again I'm gonna be I
might be wrong about this that's the
weapons you do have are gonna receive
random roles as well correct no no they
won't be Oh all your ones are gonna be
stagnant
yes fact that there are some with the
exception of there are some
that will come forward but as a drop so
the example being better Devils your
current better Devils is going to be
what it is you know I'm saying the
static whatever it is explosive rounds
yada yada yada
now when you to comes out when Newt when
you get new random drops through engrams
you get a chance they're bringing a year
a year to version of our better Devils
mm-hmm okay yeah we'll have random roles
but the one that you currently have will
never receive anything if those will
stay static okay okay yeah I wasn't I I
couldn't remember what they specifically
said about that if there was like they
were gonna receive something or I knew
that there were certain ones that
weren't coming forward right yeah I mean
beyond that I've always kind of been a I
mean the better devils will probably be
the one that I'll you know continue to
maybe use until I get a new one you know
absolutely but I've never there's never
been a major weapon that I've always
been like oh I can't live without this
kind of thing yeah not even not even
though midnight I'm trying to think I
mean in d1 I was a I probably more so
but that was because there was random
roles I always I mean like well the
Icebreaker
you never saw I mean you never saw me
without that any in anything in PVE pvp
that was just my baby so you know as far
but like I always kind of roll any cut
whatever the meta hand cannon is and
whatever like the meta exotic is sort of
what I'll go with so I'm I'm not yeah
I'm not - I'm not really thinking about
that too much as far as like what I'm
gonna be holding on to gadgets but I do
think the prep is good I think the prep
and the outreach is my this is this is
really really cool and um yeah what
about any comments on anybody can jump
in as far as the UH then you know it's
the stuff that we might be losing during
that period so they're saying no
nightfall strikes during that period and
the exotic weapons will lose that +5
power mod that kind of stuff any of that
kind of stuff effectually or and nothing
nothing major a week I mean honestly
your
yeah yeah short live the week if he I
mean if you for some reason bought the
game before and you're working up to it
that's not gonna make much of a
difference anyway if you're getting it
ready for forsaken if you bought the you
know digital collection you can play
your one and you're still going to be
giving all the way up through and if you
bump up to 380 instead of 385 whoo it's
not gonna matter so no I don't think
listen anything is going honestly make
much of a difference yeah I agree with
you and I think this is really good
stuff
I like the proactiveness on their part
by getting the community ready I think
that's cool you know and um yeah it to
me I think that the most fun part is
we're gonna have to play around with
those weapons oh yeah like I'm just
thinking right now I can put on perfect
paradox in the kinetic spot like you
know that's crazy does it then just run
around like it's really good because
let's be honest right these are drastic
changes right so we've got to get kind
of acclimated before it drops you know
cuz there's a lot you know dropping one
forsaken does drop at one time so I
think it's really cool to just get the
community and it's free right I'm an
offense with forsaken and then they get
a chance to touch this play okay this is
kind of what I wanted you know that d-1
feel you know same kind of thing because
then we're gonna have we know what
reppin rolls and all that good stuff I
think ultimately this is cool you know
and um I'm hype man I'm high bring
people like yeah the fact that it's
gonna be available to anybody you know
anybody who has d2 you know all as far
as like the the weapon system
implemented implementation that's just
gonna do I mean from a personal
standpoint of just like a lot of friends
who I told by d2 and they bought it and
they were like they never bought the
expansion for I know they're gonna play
this I know that they're gonna play it
again and I know they're gonna love it
because most of them were like Dean one
seemed like it was a really popular game
what this is really cool there so pretty
much that's the last time was just like
you know movies and we'd spice together
that kind of stuff actually one of them
is actually pretty cool I caught one of
them these movies is really hilarious
and then um yeah man so they
got the knife fail and I fall scoring
that went down as usual looks like this
is gonna be going away you know based on
the prior update and stuff like that and
um yeah man so um tomorrow we get the um
which is technically the triple triple
valid XP is then in the cruise and I'm
sorry yeah yeah no you break it again we
definitely go rematch this with scream
again will go down the right way once
you the neck you know issues get
resolved so don't worry bro um so um
that's pretty much it they talk about
that as far as double xp weekend and
then on 1 August 28th rolls we got the
new sandbox weapon slot changes and then
you know on that stuff and they show
some community art stuff so yeah man
this was a this was a big big big table
you know but a lot of stuff and overall
based on you know the crucible stuff and
you know what we're seeing going on with
strikes and matchmaking gambit infamy
ranking system you know where are you
overall coming into for safety screen
probably as excited as I've ever been
even possibly more excited than I was
definitely more excited than I was at
the launch of d2 because I hadn't laid
in the beta and I was like I was excited
I was really excited for the beta played
in the beta was not as excited for the
launch but was still excited enough
meaning I thought you know maybe we I
didn't because I didn't know what we
were getting that was sort of it I
thought maybe we were just testing PvP
game types they wanted to do static
things to make it easier on there and I
didn't realize I I still had a you know
like a hope that I'm like this this
can't be the full game this can't be the
full thing hmm now that we that they're
so open I don't think there's any real
surprises right and I mean I think all
the surprises have been shown right I
think that's a great thing
and knowing that I am I mean by all
accounts getting the game that I have
waited for now for almost two years
facts I couldn't be more excited
couldn't couldn't be more excited and
yeah it's gonna be I mean not to not to
sound too much like a fanboy no like I
still gotta be somewhat critical as a
content creator but uh but as a true
long time sort of Bungie guy as I said
going back to like Halo yeah they're
they're gonna have to do a lot to really
defer me from from loving on them for
about the next six months or a year
really I mean I yeah I'm gonna be going
for the hard cells on this game for sure
social world yeah the community has been
through a lot you know to the launch of
d2 so um you know just I remember like I
said we starting this thing flashpoint
what about you saying starting it during
the absolute Dark Ages you know and um
this thing was completely dead yeah I
think you really hit rock bottom after
cosmos iris right after that oh yeah
well like the community really turned on
it the game that was home we were in the
K hole yeah yeah Skid Row and yeah we
are we yeah cuz I mean it was completely
the darkest time I mean I felt even more
so than d1 Wendy one launched and it had
its issues you know I'm saying because
there were people that still felt the
mechanics I think the core mechanics of
the game were good they just gotta fix
certain things in regards to the grind
and I'm like we all like how could they
make these similar type mistakes again
with d2 and um yeah man it's just been a
process one brick at a time one update
at a time you know trying to get this
thing turned around and I'm with you
like obviously you know content creator
and I'm trying to stay as objective as
possible
you can't help to feel this this thing
is back like you that gets common you
don't think you know what you like
always common me it's gone and like as a
Content create I mean as a content
creator for this game I mean that that
was the reason why I started playing the
game but certainly I felt compelled to
want to do that because there were so
many different things that you could
make content about like you could make
content about just being a god I don't
know if I said this earlier but you
could be a god in the in PvP and just
show your gameplay you could be a like a
weapons roll guy in in accordance to
like PvP or PvE you could be a solo er
where you do you know you solo things
that most people can't or you find
cheese's for those things up [ __ ] for
those things or you know you do the
weekly updates those kind of things you
know I mean not to say that I'm a guy
who harps on like cheese's and glitches
but I kind of love a good cheese in the
glitch I know it makes the game a little
bit more it makes it fun for me because
it's like this is something that I'm
figuring out that nobody really knows
you know good point good and um and you
know I know always they're gonna fix it
eventually it's just for this week but
it's fun for this week but if I be
thinking for me these lands I'm laughing
too much oh yeah you know I love like
that kind of stuff it was it was like a
that was a crazy week it was a that was
it that that was in the Dark Ages and
that was more popular than probably a
lot of serenity
I remember dad I remember key points um
mayhem coming back for the first time
about how excited people were just to
play the chaotic nice because everybody
felt restricted by the 44o just stale
kind of team shot meta and for me when I
knew they turned it around really big
time was whisper quest you're like okay
this is shades of old-school destiny
running around gathering information and
finding
random things to get this ultra-powerful
reward it just took me back to things
like you know sleeper simulant b12b back
to things like outbreak crime you know
and just when you slide though blacks
talk that talk remember that strike came
out just like you see the chameleon just
galvanize and come together to figure
out these secrets that is the essence of
destiny you know say like we want the
grind we want the reward we want the
secrets you know and that's what keeps
the engagement and as much as I know
forsaken is gonna in my opinion is
really gonna turn this thing all the way
around I gotta give credit to warmind
because as much as we didn't get
everything we want narrative Lee I think
they understood the grind and the
rewards I think war mine did that well
you know I mean oh yeah getting back to
what the core got you know hardcore guys
want so it was my little time stamps on
it oh I mean I was gonna say that like
if the whisper if the whisper mission
had come out during curse of Osiris that
one mission alone my decision and that's
saying something exactly that's really
saying a lot so you know I like I I just
I just look forward like II mean even
this week I don't know if this is um
this is something I just noticed but I
think it's kind of in tone with the way
they're sort of shifting things in this
ayah in forsaken is that like sir didn't
show up in the map on Friday
yes that's Friday and the thing is is
that he shows up in the same place where
the flashpoint is every week unless it's
a planet that is a DLC so unless it's
mercury or Mars he'll be in the tower
right though most people I think at this
point wouldn't either know that at least
the people who like to comment under as
I do yes
know that there but there was kind of I
think a little element of when you mark
it on the map and it takes out any bit
of surprise anyway and all we need is a
little bit just a little bit of surprise
to find something that much more
interesting and the fact that they
didn't mark it on the map I was like
okay I know where he is
mmm-hmm
know where he is but now I can at least
say he this is where he is and it
actually means something it's like you
learn it like it's the small subtle
things from d1 that we miss and again
it's all about that mystery and it's
fine and again people have all you guys
start buzzer but it's a big deal that
you putting an icon on a map here is
like that takes away from it like you
guys watch you guys concentrate and
people were like yo where's ur nose work
where's for us so you look at our ice
creams that epoxies got okay he's here
okay cool
because dr. time took the effort to
search the actual universe defying where
he is not like you know it became so
mundane and in routine right and it's
somebody who has probably made I don't
know how many is our videos but at least
at least 50 maybe 60 I mean I don't know
how a lot probably more than any other
video I've ever done
that's where I kind of got my start um I
see the comments and I see the feedback
and I there's never been one question as
more for me posting a video of it did
someone say where is he like not what he
has but where is he exactly and that's a
big thing I'm so glad that that I I'm
waiting to see if he's on the mat today
but oh screen we're gonna bring you back
man and definitely like I said shout out
to eat boxes I feel from right now it's
episode and we got really gonna do a
rematch of this very soon make no
mistake this is too much fun and like I
said the Lords of the internet hopefully
will bless my man get him back in in the
room but uh I want to shout you out man
um yeah tell us about like what you got
going on any upcoming current content
and where can people find you well you
can find me at Wilhelm scream media
that's w IL h e with a 1 because I'm
cool and I'm a gamer em scream media on
on YouTube you can search for that
mmm you can find me at Wilhelm again
with a woman underscore scream on
Twitter or you can look for destiny to
Intel on Twitter which I actually is
kind of like another little sub meta of
me and on Facebook I'm also under
destiny to Intel man yeah I'm I try to
do at least two videos a week usually
one around Tuesday and Friday as those
are normally days where stuff updates in
the game we get the whisper mission now
on Friday and xur and Tuesday there's
going to be a lot of new stuff I mean
Friday I'm assuming there's gonna be a
lot of new stuff so I try to kind of
cover that content as well as do maybe
like one or two free-floating
free-floating videos during the week of
just general you know maybe stuff that
helps you improve
I like to say I try to target the
quality of life of the player who is who
has no friends really like that guy who
is is by himself and just trying find
his way in this world how could I help
that guy dude that is definitely needed
and at the end of the day you'll be
surprised like there is a huge part of
the community that is like that they you
know they tend to play the game so I
have a couple of you know people that in
the clan and people are not that are
that way so they look forward to that
kind of information that's really really
cool and helpful that you're doing that
and like I said shut up - uh that's the
Intel and the tower man a Facebook group
if you I don't know about a please man
it's really cool and I love love
checking out and stuff like that's why I
actually caught a lot of your videos
okay very cool yeah I mean a lot of
admin that Facebook group is well I
think that's one of the ones that I I
admin like three different things yeah
that's one of the one that's where I
came across yeah
so I write and I try to do as much like
community outreach as far as like what
like I always try to respond to every
comment on Facebook which can be
daunting because there's a lot of them
but um but I try and even on YouTube and
on Twitter I always like to respond to
everything and you know on and being
here today this was a real pleasure
I mean really again thank you guys
for having me I've this is what I really
enjoy doing which is a mocking mocking
desk really about yeah with people who
know it and who appreciate it and it's a
yeah I hope the internet God's graces
with this present because we are we are
I feel I feel personally lacking without
him
yeah bad crime and so I feel that we
definitely bring you back we're
definitely doing a rematch me I would
love it man just three passionate guys
talking destiny and really giving our
opinions on this game that we love so
yeah bans me or Lord kognito here I'm
obviously flashpoint every Fridays well
we try to get that done on twenty boxes
and um using in the morning hitting nine
o'clock because I work nights yeah also
I also the host of iron Lords podcast
and that is Sunday and that is at 1:00
p.m. Eastern and that is every Sunday is
the Lord's Day it's the Monica so yeah
man come check us out we try to have
guests of the industry or just regular
our content creators as well this week
will be a special one we're gonna get a
Dan McCall of the actual head of Xbox
Live so yeah so questions check that out
and when we do our live shows that is on
the inner circle network and uh chat
network channel so check that out
live chat is always poppin you know if
you have some time stop by and also the
shows are archived on the iron law
podcast channel as well as flashpoint
and other original content so check us
out man we trying to move out here and
yeah we're gonna wrap this thing up and
if you got anything else for the people
screen we don't get out of here man I'm
just gonna say I'm gonna be there this
Sunday all my man I appreciate food a we
gonna have some fun got to look crazy
but we have everybody and please